this week we'll be talking about
probably one of the most important
aspects of photography which is light as
in photo gruffy writing or drawing with
light it's a very content rich
conversation we're going to have and
could really easily take up a full six
week course but for our purposes here
we're going to give you something of an
overview showing you various forms and
characteristics of some light sources we
can't address every conceivable
possibility but what we can do is tweak
your curiosity I hope so that you pay
attention very close attention to what
you're seeing as you change your own
light sources looking at the shadows for
example how do they and the highlights
change as you move your light source and
observe exactly what's going on when you
make even some very minimal changes
let's start with a simple piece of
equipment a light box it's really easy
to use when you're working with
transparent material just by placing
your work directly on top of the light
box but you'll see later it can be also
another general source of lighting so
let's start with a picture of these two
petri dishes grown ecoli so that works
in this image we're seeing small pieces
of colored plastic shapes about three
millimeters across that are organizing
or self-assembling at the interface
between two solutions they're becoming a
flat assemblage at that interface and
all I did was put the glass container
holding all the material on the lightbox
and here I'm making images of sugar
crystals growing on sticks you know they
serve you that sometimes when you order
a cup of coffee so here is one rendition
on a lightbox of the sugar and what I
decided to do for the next one to simply
invert the image here's a picture that I
made a number of years ago which I still
like it's a picture about
light a better for about light it was
one of those lucky efforts when I just
set up a magnifier and the paper and in
30 seconds I got the picture very
unusual by the way so the images
intended to suggest a process of etching
with light when we talked about it in
our book no small matter about
nanoscience in this image of something I
assume you recognize by now we see a
different kind of lighting that you've
seen from previous images of the music
box I shot from above with mostly
daylight and then I turned on a little
bit more light from a tungsten lamp
above this is specific to this situation
but you might find it helpful in yours
look what happens when you just simply
click and turn a light on from the like
being off to the light being on you'll
see how the image drastically changes by
just adding an additional lab from above
this fishing reel yep that's what it is
by the way it is a fishing reel placed
in a translucent green garbage can I
thought it was fun to see what kind of
quality I could get by shooting into a
plastic translucent garbage can very
specific to say the least again just by
adding one additional light this time
inside the vacuum chamber I'm imaging we
see what starts as this kind of image
and becomes this image you'll see how it
really changes with a simple addition of
just one light in this image of a
triangular-shaped water drop it's
actually an etched area on a surface
onto which we placed water you could see
the reflection of the lamp on the water
drop we just directed a lamp on to the
water that's considered direct lighting
when I shine the lamp onto a card in
this case a gold card the light then
bounced back onto the water drop and
you'll see a completely different
quality of lighting this is called
bounce lighting
the balance gives us diffuse lighting
let's compare the two let's look at a
quick test that I made for us to see the
difference between two kinds of bounces
in this case the bounce sliding will be
used as film lighting will use a white
card and then we'll fill with a mirror
the main source of light is daylight
from a window so here's an image of the
inside of the watch that we've seen
before just with daylight on an overcast
day here i added a white card on the
side of the watch for a fill here is a
mirror reflecting the daylight again as
a fill onto the watch let's go back to
the original just daylight then the card
then the mirror back to the watch alone
then adding the card then adding just
the mirror let's zoom in to see the
subtle differences in each of these
cases now depending upon what your
material is you might see much more
dramatic changes but I encourage you to
experiment with these ideas by the way
here's another image i made this time
using both the card and the mirror as a
fill let's see them all together
light is all about shadows as well and
it is quite remarkable how small changes
can change the shadow in images how a
powerful direct light source can produce
a significant shadow and that shadow
does in this image become a very strong
compositional element here's where i'm
using the light on this wafer showing
the chip that sits next to it in this
particular image i was playing around i
decided to just use a slant of light
maybe emily dickinson would be happy
with that on this image i decided just
to make sure the light was covering the
entire waiver i actually like the first
one better but it's something to think
about about using light in terms of
making compositions in this image i'm
using a shadow to better communicate
what the grading on the surface of this
plastic is doing its diffracting the
light into various wavelengths I produce
the shadow by placing a card in front of
the light source see how the image looks
without the card shadows alone can tell
a story here we're trying to show
something called the Marangoni effect
you know when you twirl a glass of wine
we see somewhat what some people call
tears of wine it's a complex phenomenon
in this image I tried for quite a while
to make an image depicting the Marangoni
effect not at all successful finally
thinking that I should concentrate on
the glass and the shadow that is being
produced then I finally focused in on
what is the Marangoni effect on its own
as a shadow now for example looking at
this small assemblage which is about two
centimeters across I'll it this with one
light semana point it's somewhat of a
fiber optic source and you could see
carefully if you look at this image
where does the light source come
and hopefully you will figure out that
if the shadow is here then the light
source has to be around here in this
next one I added a second light source
that not only lights the device add
light to it but it also adds another
shadow and in this next one the second
light source has been altered in terms
of its direction and the height because
the shadow that it casts is slightly
longer and even more so in this final
image where the light the second light
source is very low compared to where it
was and you know that again because the
shadow is considerably longer now why
bother looking at all this it really is
once again learning to see so that when
you'd play with your own light sources
with your own devices you're going to
pay not only great attention to lighting
of your device but the shadows that the
lighting will be producing it's
important it might not seem that way at
this point but I promise you it really
is important